[Music]
not unsurprisingly given its title
ursula k le guin's novel a wizard of
earth see the first of six books of
earthsea is going to focus a lot on and
tell us quite a bit about
magic magic is something that is shot
through the entire narrative universe of
earth see in fact the two stories that
she writes before that both have to do
with wizards of one form or another and
ged the young wizard in this case is
going to be the main character and is
going to be learning about magic and
hearing about magic some of it is going
to be bitter experience and some of it
is going to be other people telling him
things now there's a lot going on in
this and we can say there's a
multiplicity
of kinds or
modes of magic so it's very important
that we don't try to
immediately systematize
some sort of rigid classification out of
this because things are in some respects
a bit more
loosey-goosey this is a novel in which
exposition is taking place in which
we're not seeing everything all at once
and there's really
three
main
we could say
users or bearers of magic in in this
work and really throughout the rest of
it
in a larger sense we could say that
everything is potentially
connected with magic in a way that we'll
talk about but here we're talking about
entities that actually
use the forces of magic or
are involved in it in their very
existence so there's what we call the
old powers of earth
and ogeon is going to use that term
after get has in fact run into one of
these the stone of the pteranodon
and there we're going to see more of
these as the series goes on there's only
one
in in this one that plays any
significant role but the next novel
tombs of ottawa is going to be about
that as well
same thing we can say for dragons
we're going to learn a lot more about
dragons in the books that follow a
wizard of earth see
already here though we learn some
important things
about dragons and dragons are you could
say
shot through and through
with magic as we're going to find out
more later on then we have human beings
and not all human beings have the
talent or the capacity or the
sensitivity
for magic as it turns out ged does and
it's not all that surprising given that
his
his mother's sister his aunt
is indeed a local witch
so perhaps there's some genetic
component to it we never really hear
that much
about that although we also do have the
example of the young girl who he meets
early on and then later on
sarat who is the daughter of an
enchantress right and so
she perhaps already has some native
talent as well
so going on uh with this
some human beings are able to use magic
some can't uh it's taken to be
part of the
the normal way of society so every
little island
will have somebody who can do magic
hopefully because then they can
help them you know cast spells on nets
so perhaps they'll catch more fish or
you know change the winds so that
they're more favorable or you know work
on the boats pick whatever you want
right
and the range of magic is incredibly
wide people use it for
all sorts of purposes as a matter of
fact we get a nice description of ged's
aunt
right here
she knew nothing of the balance and the
pattern which the true wizard knows and
serves which keeps him from using his
spells unless real need demands
she had a spell for every circumstance
and was forever
weaving charms most of her lore was mere
rubbish and humbug nor did she know the
true spells from the false she knew many
curses and was better at causing
sickness perhaps than at cursing it like
any village which she could brew up a
love potion but there were other uglier
brews she made to serve men's jealousy
and hate
and so you know what we've got here is
somebody who's fairly typical for a
low-level magic user they're just kind
of stumbling through they know a few
things some of the stuff that they think
works doesn't actually work they're
constantly meddling at other people's
affairs and other people are asking them
to do that
and so you know human beings cover a
wide range here
one of the things that is important
to at least certain kinds of magic in
earthsea is this notion
of the old or the true speech
and this is used by dragons this is also
used by human beings
as ged's
teachers are going to tell him at rook
it's important to learn all these names
of things actually ogian tells him that
as well and he's even learning this from
his aunt
because the name the true name
is connected to the thing it gives you
power over and perhaps even an
understanding
of what the thing is
and how it can be
moved shaped used appealed to
now
the heartache speech that the characters
in this use is derived from the old
speech but it's not the same thing there
are other languages as well we find out
that oskal uses its own language the
kargish lands have their own language
but we don't really learn that much
about them
dragons are a whole different ball game
we find out that dragons speak
in the old speech
they
don't speak in this the speeches of men
here we go
there's a discussion that get is having
with the dragon and he says he spoke as
ged did in the old speech for that is
the tongue of dragon still although the
use of the old speech binds a man to
truth this is not so with dragons
it is their own language and they can
lie in it twisting the true words to
false ends
catching the unwary here in a maze of
mirror words each of which reflects the
truth and none of which leads
anywhere so there's there's a different
use of this but this language
the true speech
is the language you might say of
creation
and of all the
created things dimly connected with it
still responding to it still so the true
speech is part of what the wizards at
roque have to learn and the true speech
is part of what ged learns at the very
beginning with his aunt um you know
doing this little rhyme that then ged
repeats right
and she teaches them words like that to
call down falcons and hawks and all
sorts of things like that
so magic itself
in a wizard of earth see and this is
expanded even more in the other books is
you could say
it's not just a symbol system it's not
just a technology
it is a complex reality that
works with
and folds into existence itself
because the existence of the islands
coming out of the sea that itself is
kind of magical roque island itself has
the the grove where you know these trees
are themselves magic it shifts around
the island all the time we're going to
see that become a very important thing
in later stories
so
nobody
no matter how powerful no matter how
intelligent no matter how good or evil
they are
understands or
masters magic as a totality
at best one can know some things and
then there will be other things of which
one is ignorant magic is something
greater than any one of the magical
creatures
or magic users within this narrative
universe which doesn't mean that one
simply despairs you can learn more and
more and more and you can do so with a
communal effort like what happens at
rogue
now early on in
this work we see
that magic is also gendered in a way
that people kind of take for granted in
this book we're going to see in later
books particularly
in tahanu
and in the
tales from earth sea the short stories
contained there which give us some
backstory and in the other wind
that
this leguin is reconsidering this
undoing this to some degree
but in this book magic is at the higher
level basically
for men and women
are being cast as either weaker or
evil in some way so there's these two
lines right that she brings up in
relation to ged's aunt
weak as a woman's magic and wicked as a
woman's magic
and really the two
main
women who we get to see
in this are ged's aunt who tries to take
advantage of ged that would be wicked
right
and uh the
enchantress's daughter i suppose you
could say the enchantress is a third
right who he later meets as sarat in the
court of the pteranon um and she's
definitely wicked now weak
uh
his his aunt is kind of weak right she
can't do
an awful lot
as we we've seen half of her stuff is
actually nonsense right but sarah is a
dangerous
enchantress herself
so
you know there's some interesting things
going on here that as i say are going to
be reconsidered later on
we can counter pose to that the place
where one goes to learn the high arts
roque the island that is itself
protected by
magic so no evil can approach it
guarded by where the the school itself
is guarded by a doorman to whom you must
reveal your true name in order to enter
you also have to
ask him for his true name to get out
right
and what we have here
at rogue is an order right almost like a
monastic order except not devoted to
prayer
although they are you know about
goodness in relation to the universe and
stuff like that but about understanding
shaping and you might say setting the
policy as best they can
for magic and the men at roke including
young young men or young boys like ged
are celibate right they give up their
sexuality in certain ways
they're systematically organized they
have a long tradition they have
ways of governance
they have different things that one has
to go through
and they
teach right they are themselves all
mages and what they produce are new
mages who then they send out to the
places
where they are needed and the need could
be you know at great courts or
the important islands it can be people
who like ogeon
go back to gantt and do things like stop
an earthquake right uh and then you know
they're they're the wizard there living
at rayalby or it can be
places like the
islands that get us into to protect
against dragons where normally a mage
wouldn't be sent and so roque represents
a certain way of doing
and understanding magic they are
concerned with the balance it's not the
only way that one can
learn
magic as a matter of fact ogian
who has ged as his uh his apprentice he
says to him ged my young falcon you're
not bound to me or to my service you did
not come to me but i to you
you are very young to make this choice
but i cannot make it for you if you wish
i will send you to roque island well all
where all the high arts are taught
any craft you undertake to learn you
will learn for your power is great
greater even than your pride i hope i
would keep you here with me for what i
have is what you lack but i will not
keep you against your will now choose
between rey alby and roke and later on
when when ged returns to gant um and
ogion gets him out of his uh his falcon
shape right and nurses him back to
health he says you were always my my
teacher and uh
ogion you know sort of sentiment of what
succumb says well yeah okay but you're
going to be ours too
and so um that's roque magic
there are other wizards and warlocks who
are represented as well in this
not everybody gets to go to rogue
and as a matter of fact it seems like
there are
at least different traditions
that are being represented again
something we're going to learn about
more
in the later books roque is not the only
place that has a
magic training and teaching
tradition and so one of the great
examples of this
is when ghett is traveling to oscar he's
going up to the north
and
he's being told by
a man that
go to the court to the pteranodon if you
need a sword to fight shadows with
and ged says in what in what land is the
court of the terror nun in oscar at the
sound of that name ged saw for a moment
by a trick of memory of black raven on
green grass who looked with him side
long with an eye like polished stone and
spoke but the words were forgotten
that land has something of a dark name
ged said looking ever at the man in grey
trying to judge what kind of man he was
there was a manner about him that hinted
of the sorcerer even of the wizard and
yet boldly as he spoke to get there was
a queer beaten look about him the look
almost of a sick man or a prisoner or a
slave
you are from roque he answered the
wizards of roke give a dark name to
wizardries other than your own so there
are
wizardries other than those of rogue and
oscal and the court of the taranon
represents one of those now this is
centered around one of the old powers so
we should discuss that for a bit
um in this case the old power is in this
stone
of the
pteranodon right
and there get is taken by sarah to this
this almost like little dungeon place a
dungeon
cell
and he sees a stone uh that is rough and
dank is the rest of heavy unshapen
paving stone
but he felt the power of it as if it
spoke to him aloud his breath caught in
his throat and a sickness came over him
for a moment this is the founding stone
of the tower this was the central place
this was a very ancient thing
an old and terrible spirit was prisoned
in that block of stone
she says
that is the pteranodon do you wonder we
keep so precious a jewel locked away in
our dearest horde room
and she tells him that
it was made before segoy raised the
islands of the world from the open sea
it was made itself when the world was
made and will endure to the end of the
world
it will help you defeat your enemy
and gadd says i'm not going to speak
with that spirit that spirit is sealed
in a stone the stone is locked by a
binding spell and a blinding spell and a
charm of lock and ward and triple
fortress walls in a barren land
not because it's precious but because it
can work great evil i don't know what
they told
you of it when you came here but you who
are young and gentle hearted should
never touch the thing or even look upon
it it will not work you well
and then she says i have touched it i
have spoken to it and heard it speak it
does me no harm
and we find in the rest of that
encounter that
if ged had touched the stone if ged had
even spoken to the stone instead of him
being master of it it would have
mastered him
taken him over and then allowed his
shadow to come in and turn him into a
gebbeth because ageth makes a better
slave than a man the people that he met
who suggested he go to oscar were also
slaves of the stone
and sarat and her husband the much older
sorcerer there are both trying to use
the stone to capture get and further
their own
power a little bit later after ged is
freed by
ogeon what we find
is that
this is indeed named as
one of the
old powers
here we go
ojin shook his head
but said no more for a while strange you
had strength enough to outspell a
sorcerer there in his own domain there
in oscar you had strength enough to
withstand the lures and fend off the
attacks of the servant of an old power
of earth so this is confirming the story
that
sarah tells him about this is here at
the beginning of creation it's as old as
the world
itself so that's why they call these the
old powers and they have their own
kind
of magic and all these things interface
with each other and intersect with each
other in very interesting sometimes
mysterious
ways that are revealed in these stories
you